aujourd'hui encore l'obstination d'un
homme politique peut changer le cours de
l'histoire
puis de mon île à il est obstiné il peut
changer et vous savez à quoi ça non pas
du tout mais je comprends mieux pourquoi
certains personnages et leur obstination
ont fait changer le cours de l'histoire
moi samedi soir plus que devant ça me
fait penser à la dépêche dems qui
provoquent la guerre de 1870
je sais pas pourquoi non mais c'est vrai
il ya quelque chose comme ça c'est à
dire il ya des intérêts économiques
normalement devrait être beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus en phase avec une
discussion et c'est vrai que ça et
l'obstination de quelqu'un peut arriver
je sais pas si ce serait un drame
le fait que la catalogne soit
indépendante mais encore l'obstination
et la puissance d'un homme par rapport à
un événement politique alors que toutes
ces dernières années on nous fait
comprendre qu aujourd'hui dans un monde
globalisé etc
les hommes politiques n'ont plus
d'importance là en l'occurrence il a son
importance